what we've done is we've made a musical
instrument an acoustic guitar that kind
of tries to tell you its own life story
it kind of captures its history and the
little sort of play it back to you the
guitars called the Carolyn guitar and
it's actually named after an Irish
composer and a harpist who was kicking
around at the turn of the 18th century
called Turlough Oh Carolyn and he was a
sort of itinerant musicians he travelled
from house to house and rich patrons put
him up and he would collect and compose
tunes on his way and that's why the
guitars got this kind of Celtic look and
theme as well in honor of him in
computing at the moment there's this
kind of growing interest in what's
called the Internet of Things and this
is at least to my mind it's about taking
everyday possibly non digital objects
and actually digitally connecting them
to the internet so putting sensors in
them or possibly actuators or displays
or other technologies so that everyday
stuff becomes digitally connected and
now there's lots of reasons you might
want to do that it might be about kind
of sustainable use might be about
logistics knowing where things are or
security but I think one thing that it
could be about is actually getting
things to capture memories and stories
because this might potentially make them
more valuable the inspiration kind of
couple of years back actually came from
an existing instrument I had which is a
banjo which I've kind of got here
actually which I'll kind of show you
hope people like banjo zitzer as a
Marmite kind of thing post videos of
june and the strings need changing they
probably not been changed since when it
was made which was a 1927 that much i
found out about it so this is a 1927 New
York made banjo actually made in Harlem
and it's a couple of notable things
about it firstly i think it was
beautiful look at the kind of marquetry
on the back there this is all kind of
inlaid that's a hand-carved neck it's a
hand-carved head so somebody invested a
huge amount of effort into making this
but i also just wondered what kind of
stories it could tell from new york in
1927 if that's where it was played as
well as made I mean that was prohibition
time was it in a jazz band was it in a
jazz club in a speakeasy that was raided
by the feds and it just kind of got my
imagination going and then you know the
kind of sense that only wish I knew
about all the people
this banjo and wear it have been and the
things it had seen it's older than I am
it will probably persist after I've gone
and fooled into someone else's hand so
that was the inspiration was to make an
instrument from scratch that would
capture its life story from the very
beginning from the initial choice of
woods through to its design its features
its construction and then as it's
released into the world to the various
people that play it then of course
there's the fascination of a handmade
guitar about knowing how it was was made
as well so all of that is provenance he
adds value to the object and then find
of course the stories of who actually
plays it you know if the qatari-owned or
played by someone famous then that makes
it incredibly valuable so you know some
guitars of salt for a million dollars in
the past just because of who had played
them so once we decided to do it I guess
then we kind of get a bit more into the
digital technology and the question was
how to go about doing it and there are a
number of routes open at that point we
might have chosen to put electronics of
different kinds into the instrument so
he might have opened it up and put a
wireless GPS transmitter or microphones
or may deter its own kind of access
point for Wi-Fi networks or whatever
which I think could be a really
interesting thing to do but we opted for
a different approach we decided to work
with a technology that I've spoken to
about before which was aesthetic codes
and that allows you to create
interactive surface decoration so if we
look at the instrument here the patterns
that you can see these are all these
interactive decorations and I can point
a device like a phone or a tablet at
those and I can trigger information or
upload information to the guitars of
what you would call digital footprint so
I kind of open up my steady codes app on
the phone you can downloads the app
yourself it's on iTunes and Google Play
as well so you can scan things do your
own patterns anyway I've opened it up
and I've got my kind of Carolyn
experience running let's start on the
back bizarrely and there's a nice kind
of big code on there and once it comes
into focus you can see it scans it and
then it takes me to some information
about the guitar now I've chosen to map
for the back of the guitar onto its
story so it says let me tell you my
story how I came to be where I've been
who I've met and then if I choose to
open that
it's going to take me to the guitars
blog and now this is that the guitars
live blog Carolyn guitar calm and this
is where we're telling the story of the
guitar from how it was build all the
woods that were chosen right the way
through to eventually all the people
that are going to play it one of the
ideas we wanted to play with was being
able to scan the codes at different
distances so for some people it would be
about if you were holding the guitar
more really close to it like a player
but we also wanted to involve audiences
or possibly people through a shop window
so we thought let's have a really big
code on the guitar and where's the the
biggest real estate you've got well it's
the back so we sort of put one on the
back with a view that you might display
it with its back to the audience what a
strange idea or maybe for a shop window
you could scan it which I kind of still
think is a good idea you can actually
see the initial design this is when we
were designing the guitar this is us
having the idea but it still feels
slightly weird to me to display a guitar
with its back to the audience I don't
know it's almost kind of rude or
something I can't quite figure it out
but maybe I'll get used to it you know
maybe maybe it won't feel like it's
ignoring everyone in the future on the
top of the guitar here we've got a kind
of an unusual bit of code but I'm going
to scan there we go and this is the
guitars user guide its its user manual
so you may wonder why guitar needs a
user guide one of the things you need to
know is about adjusting to pick up
volume and changing the battery it's not
so obvious on this guitar because you
have to remove the top sound hole you
can see there some little magnets on the
bottom that hold it in place and then it
tells you you can find the battery
inside and so on so the guitar does come
with the sort of user guide and you can
scan the guitar to get that and that
tells you how to do routine maintenance
jobs you actually tells you how to play
the Carolyn guitar as well it says a
press down the strings with one hand and
pick them with the other and move both
hands around until it sounds good so I'm
now going to scan this Celtic pattern on
the front of the guitar and this has
taken me to a page called performances
so here we've documented or we will be
documenting a series of performances
like on video or audio so if I open this
page we've only got one performance so
far and this is from Nick Perez's the
luthier who made the guitar so this is
Nick playing his baby for the first time
here he is basically you can tap on the
guitar and see where it's been what it's
played how its yeah and we'll invite
musicians to send us tracks or invite
audiences to upload bits of video so the
guitar eventually will become it its own
channel for the performance is that
people choose to to leave on it I know
when we did the aesthetic heads though
there were some comments mentioning the
finite amount of codes available what
sort of thinking I'm a from your point
of view it's still a live question it's
a complicated question and i thought the
comments were absolutely spot-on in that
regard compared to QR codes where you've
got in a millions of unique codes here
you've got a limited set it's probably
currently a few tens maybe 100 yes
eventually we'll be able to push that
further but it's much smaller it just
plays out in a very different way so we
actually only need a few codes to
decorate the guitar the question is of
course those codes aren't unique to us
and that other people might be using
their codes they might be putting them
on branding or bowls or logos the way
that works though is that in the app
what you can do essentially say in this
app look I'm going to view well through
the lens of the carol and guitar so the
kind of mapping between what you're
looking at in rid the real world and
what you're looking on the phone is
something you can play with you can also
make and publish your own mapping so in
the app if you want to map the guitar to
something else you could actually can
make the codes point at your own
musicians website for example so you
could kind of each owner of the guitar
could reconfigure the app for them or
their friends or whatever and you can
start to kind of mess around with it a
bit so we heard a little bit aloof you
playing are you 26 persona um that's a
good question really i think i should
prolly say at this point I think
university is probably technically its
owner just a to make that kind of clear
you
if we're starting to embed digital
materials then that's another kind of
layer so that looks suspiciously like
it's the same code although we go we've
got it again when I do we know is it's
almost like a small computer on a board
it's not quite that but it's a small
programmable board